يتدخل الجيش العراقي في كثير من النزاعات
العشائريه التي تحدث عاده في جنوب العراق
والتي يتم استخدام اسلحه مختلفه فيها
نحن كدوله دوله مؤسسات ودوله قانون ولدينا
ايضا العشائر العراقيه لهذا ما نرى ان
هناك تقاطع بين العشيره وبين القانون
بالعكس هم داعمين كثير يعني كل العشائر
عقده اجتماعات الادوات كان هناك توجيه
للمواطنين والافراد العشيره اللي ينتمي
الها المواطن انه هذا الموضوع حرام شرعا
قانونا لا يجوز وحقيقه دور العشيره او
القبائل العراقيه الاصيله كان لها دور
كبير ومشرف
بالحد بشكل كبير من استخدام
السلاح او اطلاق العيارات الناريه بدون
سبب
تقديرا بعد الرايه انا كرم وتقديري ولوجه
الله تعالى
وما شاء الله ذلك هذه الاعراض والسنن
موجوده كليتنا نتجه
عشائرنا في بعض الحالات لكن هذا لا يعني
انه انت
تخرج عن القانون